[Music]
my name is love cut hurry I'm a product
manager in Google Playstore I'm
responsible for improving our
understanding of Android apps their
content the capabilities in their
attributes and with that understanding
and knowledge we're improving how we
connect users with great digital
experiences and improve their lives hi
everyone my name is Ilya Furman I'm a
software engineer on the actions from
Google team actions from Google Offers
API is for developers to integrate with
the Google assistant and other Google
products my focus is on bringing Android
apps into the actions on Google
ecosystem so today we're super excited
to give you a sneak peek into app
actions as they've mentioned in the
keynote this morning app actions will
allow users to discover and reengage
with the capabilities and content from
your apps in just the right moment and
as an Android developer you will get an
opportunity to get surfaced across
multiple Google and Android surfaces and
improve engagement and reach for your
Android apps let's look at a couple of
examples for this with app actions users
will be able to get things done quickly
and seamlessly now imagine you're
planning a Friday night or you with your
friends
wouldn't it be great if you had a
personal assistant which could help you
accomplish tasks such as making the
dinner reservation getting movie tickets
getting a ride to the venue and building
a collage from the pictures taken during
the evening a Google assistant was
created to help users with these daily
tasks and for many of these tasks the
user may already have the perfect
Android app on the devices with app
actions your Android app can integrate
with Google assistant and participate in
these user journeys moreover these app
action suggestions will also appear on
other Google and Android surfaces to
help users get things
and discover what their apps can do with
app actions users will also be able to
go from the content they love to the
actions they can take on that content to
the relevant apps to fulfill those
actions now imagine a Lady Gaga fan is
searching for a latest hit wouldnt it be
great if that user while searching for
that information could also discover
rare to listen to our songs watch your
videos find tickets for upcoming
concerts and find updates about her this
is the ideal moment for the user to
discover capabilities from the Android
apps they already have a pack shion's
can help users reengage with the apps
they forgot they had and also discover
new opportunities and capabilities they
did not know existed really we'll be
bringing similar experiences to diverse
content such as TV shows movies books
courses sports games books and more
as an Android developer you know that
reengagement is a challenging problem
users have hundreds of apps and the
devices to choose from Android has
already did a survey couple of years ago
and found out that 77% of Android users
do not use an app after three days of
installing it and that number goes up to
90% after a month you all have worked
really hard for those app installs but
getting users to keep coming back to
your app is a harder problem now
notifications and emails they're all
tools in your toolkit but it's also
possible that they can come across as
spammy and annoying it's much better to
re-engage with the user in the right
context and in the right moment so today
you're going beyond simply predicting
the next app the user would want to open
to the next app or next action user
would wanna take in an AI first world we
want to assist users to find
capabilities and content from your apps
even if that information is very deep
inside the app so how will we make this
happen
first we're building a rich catalog of
actions or intense as we call them
essentially think of them as were plus
known these are the ways you will define
what your apps are capable of some
examples play music play game take
course order write order food these are
all intents in our catalog for these
intents
we will then build deep semantic
understanding now what do I mean by that
we will define detail schemas with
parameter specs and also define grammar
not only in English but many other
languages let's take a concrete example
of checking air quality in Los Angeles
there multiple ways a user can make that
query some examples are right here check
pollution in la find smog levels check
air quality report what's the forecast
for air pollution and many other
possible ways a user can make
that query Google will pass all of these
queries and map them into one common
built-in intent called check air quality
will also parse the right parameters
such as location being Los Angeles and
time period being today all of this will
get then passed along to the Android app
which can then take the user to the
right place inside the app and fulfill
that action as I said will also define
grammars in popular languages and
provide natural language understanding
what's really powerful about this is
that you get instant global reach
without actually having to do the hard
work of understanding languages
providing semantic understanding we
already support 16 languages and will
continue to expand that coverage how do
you participate as an Android developer
you just need to add an action to an XML
file in your apk in this file you need
to register for the intents that your
app is capable of in a supports and tell
us how to fulfill those actions why are
deep links and hylia we'll cover more of
that exactly how you can do that once
you have exposed the capabilities and
content of your apps Google will then
map user queries and context to your app
and surface you in multiple highly use
Google products starting from Android
and within Android the launcher and
smart text selection the Google Play
Store the Google assistant and the
Search app actions are not restricted to
Android P and are available on all
devices with the most recent versions of
these apps let's walk through a few
examples and by the way I'm super
excited to be walking you through this
this really amazing features you have
worked really hard for last few months
to put together this is my screen on my
phone they all apps in all apps screen
as you call it last year we introduced
the concept of predicted a pro this is
the operating system trying to predict
the next app me as a user would want to
open up it's been working really great
as they mentioned this morning we have
about 60% prediction rate on this it's
phenomenal
but this year you want to go further you
want to go from predicting the next app
to predicting the next action user would
want to take so if you take a closer
look I see two actions suggestions and
right around this time of the day
typically commuting back home I'm
relying on Google Maps to navigate me
through the Brizzy KZ barrier traffic
year to deal with around here I'm also
talking to my wife Tina catching up on
her day mostly of strategizing on how to
survive with two kids at home both of
these actions take me deep inside the
app to fulfill the task immediately the
actions are predicted based on my usage
patterns my routines my app sequences
and also in the context I'm in whether
I'm in my car whether I have my headset
on what else I'm doing as another
example if I really plug in my headset
in my iPhone I'll get an action to
resume an album or a playlist that I was
listening to on my music my favorite
music app actions are also integrated in
smart text selection in Android so let's
say I get a recommendation to a new
restaurant in the city called flour +
water and as I tap around on the text
smart text selection will recognize that
it's a it's a restaurant name it's
select the whole text it'll also try to
map what possible actions and then
further what possible apps can fulfill
that action for that given entity so as
I as I select flour + + water I get a
recommendation to use OpenTable which is
an app that I use a lot to make
reservations on my phone I can tap on
that and take me directly into the Open
Table app where I can see see more
information read reviews and make that
dinner reservation all of this is
getting powered using an on device
machine learning model any of the text
that I am selecting on the screen never
leaves my device so everything is secure
and fast
smart X elections neural network will be
able to recognize many other entities
such as TV shows movies athletes
musicians flight numbers and more
actions will also surface in Playstore
now what's really phenomenal about this
is that we all know there is an app for
everything and the Play Store is the
place where users go looking for those
apps and those capabilities so let's say
a search for Lady Gaga I will get action
suggestions to go inside the inside any
of these apps and fulfill those actions
again what's interesting is not only I
get act action suggestions for apps I
have installed but also the apps I've
not installed this is the universe of
apps that exists out there if I tap on
something that is not installed I'll go
to the details page of their app I can
then install the app and when I tap open
and again take me directly into the
right place inside the app to fulfill
that action with app actions users can
discover new ways to re-engage with the
content they already love actions will
also work in a system so let's say I ask
assistant to show me my budget on mint
assistant will understand that query
will parse it to show budget action
inside the Android app and again the
right place inside the app will get
invoked and I'll be able to fulfill that
action here I'm asking assistant what is
Lady Gaga's real name
now of course we'll understand the
question answered back with the right
information but the assistant can also
anticipate that I might be interested in
knowing more about Lady Gaga and similar
artists so I get shown actions such as
where all I can listen to her songs
watch her videos buy tickets to our
upcoming concerts back to the example I
showed earlier earlier in the
presentation it's a great way for users
to discover capabilities about the apps
they already have and they're able to do
so in the right moment again tapping on
any of these ships will take me directly
into
Android apps and then will let me
fulfill the action I was intended to do
finally as they've mentioned this
morning in the keynote you all saw this
we are exploring different ways to
surface actions in Google search for
apps that users already use a lot as an
example if you search for the latest
Avengers movie infinity war in addition
to regular suggestions you will now get
an action to Fandango app to buy tickets
assuming Fandango is an app that I use a
lot and you have it on your phone really
cool changing gears are little actions
our app actions are built as part of a
broader actions in Google developer
cloud platform this platform provides
common development tools processes and a
set of building blocks foundational
building blocks really an example of
this you already saw intern catalog this
is the taxonomy of some built-in intents
for which will provide deep semantic
understanding its structured data you
can provide Google the inventory for
your actions you can also report action
usage via firebase app indexing and get
recommended in personalized suggestions
based on context and usage patterns
identity in seamless digital
subscriptions allow hassle-free
transition across multiple device form
factors and modalities the two
modalities available number one Android
app actions that's what we have been
talking about here there is another one
which is conversational actions and
you've heard quite a bit about it in the
consumer and developer keynote these are
the ones for you to build voice powered
experiences you can also join a vertical
program and deeply integrate with Google
for enhanced discovery across multiple
Google surfaces so Google is defining a
rich catalogue of intense with schemas
and grammars as a developer you sign up
by providing us an action or an XML file
where you can register for intense that
your app supports you you also tell us
how to fulfill those intense why are
deep links and once you have done that
you get instant increase in reach and
engagement across multiple Google and
Android surfaces Ilya can you walk us
through some of this and show us how
this is working thank you so much love I
hope you guys are as excited as we are
about the opportunities offered by app
actions you must be wondering how do I
sign up let me walk you step-by-step
through the process of setting up
actions for your app and the core of app
actions is actions that XML a new
configuration file that you can include
in your android apk actions that XML
enables you to register for intents and
to define fulfillment for those intents
now when we talk about intents in the
context of actions on Google we're
talking about semantics intents these
are defined by the actions in Google
platform these intents describe what
your action does in a language that
Google can understand intents can be
built in coming from that rich catalog
of intends that love mentioned earlier
or custom intents that are defined by
the developer
and while intends to describe what an
action does fulfillment describes how
your app does that action for Android
apps fulfillment connects the semantics
intent to the Android intent in the app
together indents and fulfillment define
actions and actions that XML is how you
provide actions in your Android app once
you've defined your intense and your
fulfillment you can help us personalized
action suggestions by integrating usage
logging into your app using api's from
firebase app indexing you can also
extend your reach beyond Android
Liability conversational actions and you
can enhance the way actions are
presented to the user using slices a new
UI frame for framework for surfacing
deep in app content this is just a quick
high-level overview of the app action
setup process
let us now walk through each step in
detail starting with intents
as love mentioned earlier app actions is
built upon a new catalog of semantic
intents that are published by Google as
part of the actions on Google platform
for each intent we define a grammar that
helps us recognize user queries and
parameters that we can infer from the
query and pass into your app the intent
catalog helps us organize the world of
actions so we can show the right actions
to the right user at the right time we
expect that most developers will
register for one of our built-in intents
with built-in intents you give Google a
deep understanding of what your app does
moreover with built-in intense you don't
need to worry about natural language
understanding I imagine after i/o you
might want to ask your assistant to get
a right to SFO or book a taxi to San
Francisco Airport or to order a cab to
the San Francisco Airport with built-in
intense you don't need to worry about
all the different ways in which a user
can express the same intent Google takes
care of natural language understanding
your app just needs to provide
fulfillment built an intense give you
support from many languages right out of
the box and they provide a one-stop shop
for getting access to multiple UI
surfaces we will be adding more and more
intense into the catalog over time so if
your particular use case is not covered
chances are it will be soon and you will
have a way to request new intends to be
defined and if your use case is truly
unique you can define a custom intent
and build your own grammar using actions
console the equivalent of play console
for actions on Google developers it is
important to distinguish between
semantics intents that are defined by
actions on Google and Android intents a
feature in the android framework as
Android developers you're probably
familiar would enter it in tense they
describe specific Android operations in
a way that allows Android apps to talk
to each other
semantics intents on the other hand are
part of our larger catalog that extends
beyond Android and includes the
assistant Google search and other
services for Android apps actions that
XML is what defines the mapping between
semantics intents and
specific Android intents in your app of
course you can build multiple ways to
fulfill the same semantic intent across
different types of devices for example
let's say you're a bank and you want to
support the check account balance intent
on Android your mobile banking app is a
great way to support that intent but
separately you could build a
conversational action so you can support
a voice only experience on Google home
or smart displays using the tools that
you've seen earlier in the actions in
Google Talk and you'd like to learn more
about how to transition from building
for your Android app to building
conversational experiences you can come
to a session dedicated to that on
Thursday morning today we will focus
specifically on integrating your Android
apps into the app actions ecosystem now
if you're an Android developer you're
probably already familiar with intent
filters a native mechanism in Android to
expose intents outside of the app intent
filters define content types and data
URIs that your app can accept and those
data URIs can come in the form of HTTP
URLs or perhaps URLs in your own custom
app specific scheme actions that XML
defines how a semantic intent inferred
from a user's query or the user's
context can be converted into a URL to
open into your app enter its intent
filter logic then converts that URL into
a specific Android intent to launch in
your app now why do we use URLs to
connect semantic intents and enter it
intense deep link URLs are part of a
larger discussion you can link your app
URLs to your web content using verified
app links or sitemaps with Google
structured data programs you can
precisely define the specific content
that your app can support and with
firebase app indexing you can enable
Google to personalized action
suggestions by by identifying what users
do when they use your app all of these
different features and programs use URLs
to identify content in your app so we've
talked about intense now let's switch
gears and talk about fulfillment
fulfillment describes a specific
mechanism to invoke a particular action
in your app fulfillment is what tells
Google how to determine this specific
deep link URL to open for a given
semantic intent with actions that XML
you can use one of two models to provide
fulfillment for a semantic intent in the
URL template model we use the parameters
of the semantic intent to dynamically
construct a fulfillment URL at runtime
actions that XML provides a URL template
with placeholders for specific
parameters at runtime we then take those
parameters from the user intent and pass
them into your URL this model is ideal
for action centric apps with deep link
api's in the content driven model we
discover the fulfillment URL through
your web content or your structured data
we use the user's query to find the
relevant content in your web presence
and then we use actions that xml to
connect the URL of that content with the
appropriate intent of course you must
verify ownership of your web content
before you can use it in your app you
can use androids verified app links or
connect your app with your website using
the Google search console all that's
really needed for content driven
fulfillment is linking your actions that
XML to your web pages but the content
driven fulfillment model works best with
structured data while semantics intends
describe the verbs that your app
supports structured data can describe
the nouns the inventory of your app
google provides a variety of structured
data programs some of them use web
markup
some of them use hosted data feeds many
of you probably already participate in
these programs you can use our
structured data developer site to see
there is a vertical program that fits
your specific use case and you can also
find a link to the tool that you can use
to test your markup so how do you
actually submit your actions that XML to
Google
perhaps you're developing your app in
Android studio and you can include your
actions of XML in the same android
project and the same apk that you submit
to the Play console Play console then
parses your actions like some
and registers your actions in the
actions on Google database this
registration allows your app to respond
to queries and appear in suggestions in
various Google products and how can you
test that your actions work before you
submit your app to play you can use our
new plugin for the Android studio called
the app actions test tool with this tool
you can validate your actions that XML
has submitted to actions on Google in
the special preview mode which makes
your actions available just for your own
developer account you can then test how
Google assistant would invoke your app
with different combinations of semantic
intents its semantics intent parameters
but enough talk let's take a look at
some demos in this first example I will
show you how the URL template based
fulfillment model works I will show you
my favorite taxi app that we built a
couple of weeks ago for this session
integrates with the order ID built in
intent now can we switch the slides for
just one moment switch to slides thank
you the order ID intent comes with four
parameters for pickup location drop-off
location pickup time and drop of time
each of these parameters is defined as a
schema.org entity and you can see on the
slide how we parse out the parameters of
that entity from a user invocation and
now let's switch to the laptop so you
can see on your screen is Android studio
and in my android project I have my
actions of XML file open you can see
here that I'm registering my taxi app
for their order write intent and I'm
providing a URL template in this case it
happens to be an HTTP URL but you can
also use in app your app specific URLs
or intent your eyes in this case there
are placeholders in the into your URL
template for two parameters for the
drop-off and pickup address these
parameters are then mapped to the
parameters of the intent the
placeholders I'm after the parameters of
the intent
now let's bring up the app actions test
tool when I click the load actions
button the tool will validate my actions
of XML parse it and submitted to actions
on Google in preview mode so I can test
what would happen if I pass this
particular parameter when I click run
oops
for some reason my phone decided to
switch in landscape mode but okay I
think I think I made the point the two
passes were a parameter to the to the
app and the way this happens is the tool
simulates what Google assistant would do
if it if it received a particular
semantic intent with particular
parameters
more specifically the two constructs and
action link and you might have seen
action links earlier today in the
actions on Google Talk and this is a
deep link to a specific semantic intent
in their system let's switch the slides
please
we've talked about the template-based
fulfillment model now let's talk a
little bit about how the content-driven
model works we have worked with Coursera
to integrate their app with app actions
Coursera is signing up for the take
course intent from our catalog this
intent today takes a single parameter of
type scheme in a tour course and you can
see how we're parsing
properties of that schema or course from
a user invocation
now Coursera happens to annotate all of
their course web pages with structured
data and we can infer from the
structured data what the name of the
course is what the course is about and
what the specific deep link URL for that
course is and since Coursera is using
verified app links we can use the same
URL to open the Coursera app on the
device let's switch to the left of
please queue
here is the actions that the what
actions of XML could look like for
Coursera cursor is signing up for the
take course intent and for the course
parameter of that intent there is an
inventory reference an entity set
reference that ties this intent
registration to scheme that or course
structures located on these web pages
and the URL template in this case just
takes the URL discovered from structured
data and as a referrer per am again we
can bring up the app actions test tool
submit actions into in preview mode and
let's see what what would happen if I
wanted to study machine learning
the Coursera app opens to the specific
deep link for the machine learning
course and if demo gods smile at us
perhaps we can also see what would
happen if I try the query what is deep
learning
so here Google has given us a the system
is given as a knowledge answer
explaining what deep learning is but
underneath that answer there is a
suggestion to learn more by taking a
course with Coursera and when I click on
that link it opens a specific deep link
to a course in the Coursera app let's
switch back to slides please so you've
seen how you can define your intense and
fulfillment using the actions with XML
configuration file you can further help
us discover your apps help users
discover your apps button by integrating
usage logging into your app using
firebase app indexing API is action
logging through firebase app indexing
helps Google provide personalized
suggestions based on the user's context
and usage patterns for example if you
often listen to jazz music on your
evening commute let me show you a
suggestion to play cool jazz radio when
you get into the car or if if we know
that you keep watching altered carbon we
may give you a helpful suggestion when
the next episode comes out action log in
can help your app rank better in these
personalized action suggestions this is
not a new API but we have made changes
to the API specifically to support app
actions you can now tie each reported
event to a specific semantic intent and
specific parameter values of course
users remain in control of their data at
all times they can see and control all
of their logged activity using the my
activity website and they can opt out of
action log and altogether I will now
pass the stage tool of who will talk to
you about how you can enhance your
actions by adding rich UI and
conversational fulfillment Thank You
Ilya and thank you demo gods this was
amazing to see this in like happening in
front of us and it was incredible I want
to give a big shout out to multiple
teams multiple product teams that have
worked together on this feature I mean
if you imagine right you have Android as
a developer ecosystem and you've got
actions on Google it's never easy when
you try to make both of these ecosystems
work together as team
you're just seeing here to recap as a
developer you could participate in
actions by registering your action
registering your app and the actions in
your app in the actions or XML file you
can provide fulfilment with URLs either
URL template or a structured data you
can report action usage using firebase
app indexing to help your app rank
better
however app actions as we think of it is
just the first step in your journey with
actions the more ways with which you can
enhance actions and further increase
engagement with users first you can use
slices to enhance action represent
representation through rich UI templates
and second you can build conversational
experiences and multi-modality
experiences for google assistant let's
take a quick look slices enhance action
presentation through templates these
templates are designed to appear outside
the app in Android system UI like
notifications or and go other Google
platforms like assistant and search
these templates support flexible layouts
interactive controls like sliders and
toggles and dynamic radar like real real
time pricing served directly from the
app on the users phone slices are
compatible with devices on API 19 or
above essentially it enables you to get
get to about 95% of Android devices that
are out there pretty cool this your
slices will launch on Google search on
Android if you want to learn more we
have a whole session dedicated to slices
it's tomorrow at 8:30 on stage for hope
you see you see you there but what about
all these new devices and platforms that
are coming in to market things that you
heard from Brad and develop a keynote
this afternoon you can extend your
services to new devices and form factors
by building conversational actions and
multi-modality experiences for Google
assistant again to learn more please let
in our technical session on Thursday
morning
entered at 10:30 on stage for actually
it's 9:30 my bad so hope you are as
excited about this project as we are
many Android developers are already
building support for actions and hope
you will as well if you're interested
please let us know at G dot go slash app
actions you can learn more about the
project on that page sign up for further
updates newsletters will be starting an
early access program next month
hopefully some of you will sign up for
that we'd love to hear your feedback and
very specifically on built-in intents
that the catalog that we're building for
intense over the next two days we have
quite a few venues to answer any burning
questions that you have their presence
in office hours
we have presence in both sand boxes in
Android as well as assistant where we
can show you more of these things live
and answer any questions that you have
again we have two more sessions one on
slices tomorrow morning and one on
conversation actions on assistant day
after tomorrow and fairly soon you'll be
able to upload the actions or an XML
file with you Ray on your app using play
Play Developer console Thank You we'd
love to hear from you if you've any
feedback give it on give it to on this
to us on this website thank you so much
[Music]
you